[Music]  you went to this place or something my  own stratosphere  he started with nothing but built a  fortune worth 20 billion dollars wall  streeters say he's intimidating and  relentless  carl identifies companies that he thinks  are undervalued and he'll put pressure  on the ceo to do what he wants the most  feared corporate raider in history  activist serrater called me whatever you  want i made this money because the  system is so bad not because i'm a  genius  what do you think drives me it isn't  money strangely enough people on wall  street are tremendously overpaid the ceo  was just nefarious his job in his mind  was to make himself a lot of money at  the expense of shelves  we  shield us literally a trillion dollars  is he a activist investor representing  the little guy  or corporate raider from carl icahn  one thing you have to remember doesn't  stay forever if you're not careful